so a lot of you may know this I'm
actually a stand-up as well as hosting
the show
which means I tour around the country
which means I stay in more than my fair
share of hotels I don't know if you guys
have stayed in a hotel recently but they
have this new sign in the bathroom now
that says we care about the environment
a towel on the floor means please
replace a towel on the rack means I'll
use it again please be green reuse your
towel I don't know about you but
whenever I see this I feel like they're
trying to get away with something like
it doesn't feel quite straightforward
like they're not being straight with me
I have a sassy reaction every time in my
brain I see the sign I go excuse me this
is a loan in my hotel like oh you equip
each room with a fully functional power
guzzling refrigerator that I can't even
use because it's jammed with tiny booze
bottles and $12 candy bars and you want
me to be green
here's a cool idea watch my damn towels
and what's this the hotel business
center terrific a room where the lights
are always on and there's a dozen
computers running 24/7 so businessman
can casually look at porn and a
housewife from Rhode Island can
accidentally print out 45 copies of her
flight itinerary hey why don't you get
down to business and watch my towels
it's not over and it's not just hotels I
find watch my damn towels to be the best
most empowering phrase for pretty much
anything whenever you're tired of
getting from something wash my damp
towels it's always there for you bye hey
Internet videos oh we're going there
you're gonna make me watch a 30-second
commercial just to see a 15 second clip
of a cat sneezing even when I know the
cat isn't seeing a cent of that ad
revenue
hello this cute cat the commercial throw
up a printout I'll ignore pay the damn
cat Allah
nope they'll come back then they're not
just watching that is terrifying if I
came home and flipped on the lights and
Nate what's in my house
no no more aah hey Gandalf yeah
hey candle that's right Ken oh you're
gonna tell Frodo to not use the ring of
Sauron because it's evil but then you're
going to send them on a journey and put
them in a bunch of situations where he
absolutely needs to use that ring
I got an unexpected journey for you take
your wrinkly old ass down to the
laundromat I wash MA damn 12:00
it's the worid in town